the Joe Rogan experience it's no
different than when we watch America
have you ever watched American Idol hey
how come you know how come you're not
happy you're not a star yet well because
I don't know how the business works I'm
gonna get in front of people that can
make me a star yes that goes with any
that goes the food all the fighters to
know how do I get in the UFC I don't
know okay that's the thing you got to
find a way in and if they don't know how
to get in and they're stuck living in
the woods somewhere and you know trying
to be if they don't see that clear path
they might not have the same level of
commitment so they might slack off or
find something else to do there you it's
what we started about this because
Brendon was saying that if you're not in
the UFC you're not [ __ ] yeah I mean I
think that's a crazy perspective because
when I look at like we're talking about
Lima like there are guys out there like
I look at Lima and I go he might be able
to beat everybody I really believe that
that guy's [ __ ] terrifying we knocked
out Michael venom page yeah I'm like
look he might be able to beat everybody
yeah to say no like come on man
watch that guy fight look at his [ __ ]
power look at the way he knocked out
course coffee look at those [ __ ] leg
kicks man he tortures guys with those
leg kicks
he's so powerful let's here's the thing
though let's not forget when roid left
he was still one of the top guys yes I
see okay and just because and and look I
don't know I'm not trying to like ding
her dawg
but what Dana does very well is he he
develops the narrative and then the
media runs with that narrative very well
so they they before he even before they
even put pen to paper Dan has already
wrote the story for them because he know
he's already gave them the narrative
like you and I are talking about earlier
with Connor yeah he made Donald Cerrone
he caused him losing 40 seconds Dana
came out and said it's not that Connors
are cowboys bad he said Connor looked
that good that narrative was written for
all the media to go ahead and follow
because that's before they wrote pay in
the paper that's what the narrative was
he wrote the narrative for them I just
feel that like look there's guys out
there that can cross boards all across
theme is one of them Patrice shells one
of them there's guys I think at 135
pounds that we have that can do it as
well we've got tons of guys not just us
even in one but I would put our guys I
would
I say our but I just say because I came
from Strikeforce and we got no respect
man it was so hard join yours guys
integrated with the UFC we realized how
many of them became champions Luke
Rockhold and how many of them were world
class guys Mousasi there's so many got
Tim Kennedy yeah so many guys came over
from Strikeforce you have to remember
this is I've been getting criticized for
a year not criticized I've been being
told
I've been told for years that I was
never a top guy for years because I was
in Strikeforce right and I said well I
also know what the guys in the UFC are
making and I'm making more in
Strikeforce so I'm gonna stay here like
at the end of the day to me it it's
about making money
right like boy this is this is I'm a
prizefighter let's talk about that is it
weird though that like this is the only
sport MMA is the only sport where you
have these names of these organizations
and they're more like boxing nobody
gives a [ __ ] of as a WBC title or the
WBO title they don't care they care is
it Deontay Wilder
is here fighting I want to see him fight
Tyson Fiore I don't give a [ __ ] if it's
for the bubblegum title it doesn't mean
anything to me but for MMA for some
reason because the promotion's become
like the NFL or the NBA
it becomes the big thing we know there's
world-class fighters everywhere it's not
like basketball or football we're the
best guys are definitely playing in the
NFL there's so many different
organizations and I almost feel like
fighters are hampered by the names of
these promotions I almost think like
we'd all be better off if it was just
MMA you know to call it the UFC the
problem with that is it's great because
everybody knows is a very high quality
to the UFC events the production value
is amazing there's so much attached to
it and so much history but at the end of
the day it's about MMA fights that's
what it's about and whether it's in
Bellator or 1fc
it's about how good are these matchups
how good are the fighters what am I
gonna say well I believe it all started
when I believe I believe it all started
when credentials were taken away from
top mm a media organization
our websites and saying hey if you do we
don't like what you say you're not gonna
get a credential II get in so then they
replace they brought in the mate the
other media websites or whatever it was
USA Today whatever was other media sites
that came in and just said it's all
about UFC it wasn't a sport anymore it
was a UFC brand and we had the best
fighters and once you took away sure
dogs credentials you know all the other
people that were doing what other
companies at that time had web they took
those credentials away now whoever came
in was like well [ __ ] they're gonna do
it to those big-time you know MMA
websites why would they would do the
same [ __ ] to me if I don't tow the line
and that all of a sudden became like
fighters now when you see them put it's
all about UFC it's not about anything
that they're doing like you as a fighter
I think look even though it's an
individual sport and sure you guys
should be pumping your organization I
get it but you should also be pumping
you because after you're done the UFC
will be fine you need to worry about
building your brand whatever it is you
do to make you big yeah and and it's all
for I'm all for the organization the
organization does a lot for the fighters
I'm not here to piss on any company or
any organization they need to make sure
though that they're doing what they can
to make as much money as they possibly
can and I go back to the strike forcing
I was making almost double what the guys
were making in the top five in the UFC
at the time now there was a lot of talk
about backroom bonuses and this and that
but I was I was on privy to a couple of
those backyard bonuses when we got
bought out and I went over there they
were not what I was making on the other
side of the rope so just to give you an
example when I came over they were like
oh wow you're making that they were like
whoa what do we got to do you only have
one fight left and I was like well he
got a match or at least beat it you know
like what I'm making now and then in the
thought process was like where the [ __ ]
am I gonna go though Joshua kind of
[ __ ] stepping on your own dick here
you know cuz it's tricky right because
yeah and negotiate correctly no I
couldn't really and that was the thing I
couldn't really negotiate at the time
and I was just like [ __ ] all right well
let's play this out so I took the least
amount of fights I could possibly take
wondering if Bellator was gonna be
around long and you know and if Scott
was gonna stick with the UFC or if he
was gonna try to go do his own promotion
again I know a lot of a lot of my
relations
chips come from people that have been
around with Coker to me is I think one
of the best guys if not the best cop
ever done business with I've learned a
lot from watching him on how he
approaches not just fighters but the
promotion itself you know I the one
thing I admire the most about him is
that like you just don't you don't need
to [ __ ] on other people like the UFC or
one to say that my organization is the
best he takes that martial arts attitude
and approach to a lot of things and he
never never heard him say bad things
about Dana White never in a public
private conversation and I I have golf
with I play golf with him a lot I have
lunch with him a lot I've never once say
him heard him saying anything bad about
Dana White or anybody else at the UFC
that's not his approach he's approaches
I'm gonna have fights I'm gonna try to
make my guys that are fighters as much
money as I can and my organization gonna
do something that we're gonna do and let
them do what they're gonna do I
appreciate that
yeah he's a very universally loved guy I
would really like cross-promotion fights
[Applause]